à faire ici c'est difficile c'est
novateur et j'espère que vous allez nous
encourager
un pas de plus vers les étoiles
comme les autres c'est l'un des
entrepreneurs les plus fascinants au
monde
l'homme derrière Peppa s'attaque aux
géants de l'aérospatiale et de
l'industrie automobile ainsi qu'aux
sociétés pétrolières et au service
public d'énergie et c'est lui qui
gagneur le genre de personne qu'on voit
peut-être une fois par siècle et qui
vient changer notre façon de fonctionner
et notre façon de voir le monde
les gens avaient encore peur d'acheter
des livres en ligne à l'époque offrir
des services financiers sur Internet
c'était donc une idée assez
révolutionnaire ça a donné Paypal le
service de paiement en ligne
c'est une chose de diriger une
entreprise d'un milliard de dollars et
le masque lui en a quatre mon idéologie
personnelle est partagée j'essaie de
faire progresser les questions liées à
la planète comme l'énergie durable mais
aussi la technologie spatiale afin
d'établir une ville autosuffisante sur
Mars
de l'intelligence artificielle à
l'industrie automobile sans oublier
solarcity combien d'autres peuvent dire
j'ai ma propre compagnie de fusée pas
beaucoup
ilon a complètement changé notre façon
de penser au voyage spatiaux vous voyez
ce que c'est un compli avec ses fusées
réutilisables la science-fiction des
années 1950 devient réalité les fusées
atterrissent comme elles ont toujours
été censées faire c'est comme atterrir
sur un timbre c'est incroyablement
difficile mars l'appel maintenant
je suis convaincue que ça va se produire
avant ma mort
a changé à jamais l'automobile
il a réussi à abattre un mur qu'on
prétendait indestructible toutes les
grandes compagnies automobiles passent
maintenant en voiture électrique
cette révolution c'est un seul homme qui
l'a fait
c'est un genre d'Iron Man mais en vrai
son histoire est loin de se terminer on
a donc plus qu'à le regarder et à se
laisser captiver par ce qui reste à
venir
beaucoup de gens pensent que les
entrepreneurs qui réussissent se
trouvent au bon endroit au bon moment
avec le bon produit ou le bon service
c'est faux pourquoi ne pas se contenter
des 25 millions de dollars qu'il gagne
en vendant leur première entreprise
pourquoi lance-t-il alors une deuxième
ou une troisième entreprise les
entrepreneurs en Syrie sont un peu des
gens obsédés ils ont une forte
motivation psychologique et ça
généralement un lien avec leur enfant
il en lui masque n'est à Pretoria en
1971 sa mère est canadienne et son père
sud-africain
il a grandi en Afrique du Sud et il a eu
une enfance très libre
il avait la passion de l'ingénierie de
la physique et des sciences
le petit ilon fréquente l'école primaire
water Claude quand ses parents divorcent
il part vivre avec son père à l'âge de 9
ans
après le divorce de ses parents ilon se
sentait peiner pour son père qui vivait
seul il a donc décidé d'aller vivre avec
lui plus tard il a affirmé que ça avait
été une terrible erreur
il a avoué ne pas avoir une bonne
relation avec son père il a dit des
choses très dures au sujet de son père
c'était apparemment une situation très
désagréable son père était ingénieur et
il en considère que sa disposition pour
le génie lui vient en grande partie de
lui même si c'était un homme troublé
d'après scandiyland il possédait une
formation très pointue en génie
aussi
dylône avec son père celle qui
l'entretient avec sa mère semble être
très solide et se renforcer de jour en
jour
sa mère est probablement la plus grande
des optimistes elle est adorable elle
est vraiment spécial
on la voit même dans le New York Times
c'est génial et je suis mannequin depuis
50 ans il suffit de persévérer d'être
gentille et disponible et de se montrer
surprise quand on devient soudainement
la mère de la mariée puis la grand-mère
la mère Dylan l'a beaucoup soutenu au
fil des ans elle ne cesse de chanter les
louanges d'ilon sur Twitter elle est
très fière de lui
incroyable elle a environ 69 ans et
vanity faire la déclare fille de l'heure
c'est une mannequin en demande qui fait
des campagnes pour de grandes marques
dans le monde entier c'est une des
femmes âgées les plus élégantes que vous
ne verrez jamais
essayé à plusieurs reprises et de
maintes façon de réparer sa relation
avec son père il a fini par abandonner
parce qu'il ne croit plus que celui-ci
soit capable de changer
il a parlé ouvertement du fait qu'enfant
il passait beaucoup de temps seul il se
souvient encore d'une maison vide ou
résonne seulement des pas au loin et il
ne veut plus jamais vivre ça
les entrepreneurs les plus brillants ce
sont les expériences de la vie qui
déterminent la réussite ultérieure en
particulier celle de la jeunesse quand
on se penche sur l'enfance de ces
individus on relève un certain nombre
d'expériences néfastes importantes comme
le rejet ou l'intimidation à l'école
c'est ce genre d'événements qui motive
quelqu'un qui lui donne quelque chose à
prouver ces gens veulent reprendre la
maîtrise de leur monde ils cherchent
donc à occuper un emploi de haut niveau
à devenir entrepreneur ou PDG ce qui
donne du pouvoir de la force du contrôle
tout ce qu'ils n'ont jamais eu dans leur
jeunesse c'est une importante source de
motivation pour de nombreux
entrepreneurs
Elon Musk étudie à l'école secondaire
Brian Stone de Pretoria où il obtient de
très bonnes notes
il a eu une enfance assez difficile il
aurait notamment été victime
d'intimidation n'importe quel enfant qui
montre une telle intelligence et un tel
intérêt à l'école peut attirer
l'attention des petites brutes il a été
hospitalisé après une bagarre
il se faisait harceler à l'école il a
même perdu connaissance sous l'écho à un
moment donné ce n'était pas encore
évident à l'époque il s'agissait d'un
génie du marketing
et de judo pour se développer un peu
plus physiquement et il a grandi un peu
il a eu une poussette croissance ça lui
a permis d'affronter les brutes qui le
tourmentaient
à l'école secondaire de Pretoria pour
garçon
Ilona fréquenté notre école de 1986 à
1988 l'année de son entrée à
l'université il excellait en sciences
mais aussi en informatique il a obtenu
son diplôme avec mention pour les
sciences et pour l'informatique
je me souviens de ces notes parce que je
les ai conservées dans mon carnet il
était très certainement le premier de sa
classe en sciences j'ai enseigné à
beaucoup de garçons au fil des ans mais
j'ai toujours gardé le souvenir
d'illonnes je ne pourrais pas vous dire
à quelle pupitre chaque garçon
s'asseyait mais je me rappelle qu'il est
à l'arrière de la classe plongé dans son
travail il n'était pas de ceux qui
veulent qu'on s'occupe tout le temps
d'eux on est toujours très fiers de
chaque garçon mais d'un point de vue
personnel ayant enseigné les sciences à
heilen j'aime croire que j'ai apporté ma
petite contribution pendant ces années
formatrices j'ai lu qu'il aimerait se
rendre sur Mars j'espère qu'il va le
faire bientôt mais à la façon Star Trek
pour qu'il m'y invite
[Musique]
Elon Musk a toujours été différent des
autres et se lancer très tôt comme
entrepreneur
en 1984 il vend son premier logiciel
commercial ce succès technologique
inspiré de la science-fiction laisse des
entrevoir son avenir il s'intéresse aux
ordinateurs depuis l'âge de 10 ans il
s'est avéré très habile dans le
développement de programme
informatique pour 500 dollars
quand on lui a demandé ce qu'il
distingue des autres il en a répondu
qu'il y avait des choses qui étaient
très évidentes pour lui durant sa
jeunesse mais dont la logique échappait
aux autres enfants
comment fonctionne la conduction comment
un interrupteur édifile peut allumer une
ampoule des choses qui étaient
immédiatement claires et évidentes pour
lui mais que les autres ne comprenaient
pas automatiquement surtout à l'âge de
14 ans
il jouait beaucoup aux échecs où il faut
anticiper les déplacements de
l'adversaire et ça lui enseignait
réfléchir aux étapes à venir même plus
jeune ilonne chercher donc des idées
d'entreprises à court terme mais aussi
de projets qui pourraient s'insérer
ultérieurement dans ces plans plus
ambitieux
[Musique]
après avoir obtenu son diplôme d'études
secondaires mosque fréquente brièvement
l’université de Pretoria avant de se
décider à quitter l'Afrique du Sud
l'histoire de la richesse et de
l'Ascension d'illonne Mask est liée en
partie au rêve américain il n'a jamais
cru qu'il réaliserait ses ambitions en
Afrique du Sud il voulait vivre aux
États-Unis et faire partie de ce milieu
ça ne lui a pas été possible au départ
il a d'abord dû émigrer au Canada
masque passe deux ans à l'université
Queens en Ontario
[Musique]
il a financé ses études au Canada et aux
États-Unis en obtenant des bourses et en
travaillant en temps partiel il n'avait
donc pas vraiment beaucoup d'argent dans
une rédaction universitaire devenue
célèbre il parlait déjà de son désir de
conquérir certains domaines comme
l'Internet l'exploration spatiale
l'énergie solaire l'intelligence
artificielle et les interfaces
cérébrales
avec des diplômes en gestion et en
physique mosque abandonne ses études au
doctorat à l'Université Stanford en 1995
pour faire son chemin à Silicone Valley
il a quitté l'université Stanford à
peine deux jours après son arrivée il
avait lancé une entreprise appelée
ziptou avec son frère kimbal c'était une
sorte de PagesJaunes en ligne qu'il
vendait aux journaux à l'époque il s'est
enrichi en vendant la compagnie ils
l'ont vendu à compacte pour environ 307
millions de dollars
ça lui a rapporté à peu près 22 millions
de dollars ce qui est une somme énorme
comme il le fera toujours par la suite
il en a réinvesti la moitié dans son
entreprise suivante qui allait plus tard
devenir Paypal
après avoir secoué l'industrie
traditionnelle de la publicité papier
avec ziptou Mosk s'attaque ensuite au
marché financier mondial avec sa
nouvelle entreprise le concept de excom
était d'offrir des services financiers
complets ça semble presque archaïque
maintenant mais à l'époque la création
d'une suite de services financiers sur
internet était une idée plutôt
révolutionnaire
la stratégie de mosque pour ex.com et
des plus originales il offre des
récompenses en espèces au nouveau client
et créer un système de paiement entre
utilisateurs
ma première impression d'ylène c'est
qu'il était très déterminé et très
passionné parce qu'il s'apprêtait à
faire il m'a semblé très clair dès le
début qui ne joue pas selon les règles
habituelles de la vie des affaires ou de
quoi que ce soit d'autre je n'avais donc
qu'à me laisser entraîner dans sa danse
[Musique]
au début ces intentions n'étaient pas du
tout faciles à interpréter surtout parce
qu'on ne savait jamais comment il allait
réagir c'était la première fois que je
travaille avec quelqu'un qui pense comme
lui qui parle comme lui ou qui a autant
confiance en ce qu'il fait quand
lui-même c'était très étrange pour moi
qui avait grandi dans la oa ou peut-être
est-ce étrange pour tout le monde je
n'en sais rien
[Musique]
des 10 pires idées d'entreprises en 1999
Elon Musk jouera pourtant un rôle
déterminant dans le développement de
l'Internet en se concentrant sur la
création d'un système de paiement
mondial on l'a surtout connu grâce à
PayPal c'est à ce moment là qu'il a
commencé à faire parler de lui Paypal
allait transformer les opérations
financières en transaction en ligne cela
allait-il faciliter les choses les
rendre plus efficaces ça peut sembler
évident maintenant mais à l'époque les
gens avaient encore peur d'acheter des
livres en ligne leur demander de
regrouper toutes leurs données
financières en un seul endroit n'était
donc pas une proposition gagnante le but
de l'entreprise combattissait alors a
toujours été d'apporter quelque chose de
très positif à l'humanité ilon pensait
déjà depuis longtemps à l'espace et au
panneau solaire on était donc conscient
qu'il s'agissait uniquement pour lui
d'un tremplin vers de plus grands rêves
Paypal devient rapidement le système de
choix pour le paiement en ligne en
quelques mois ces utilisateurs passent
de quelques milliers à plus d'un million
le service de paiement entre utilisateur
a décoller très rapidement ça attirait
énormément l'attention le marché aux
enchères en ligne évite devenu populaire
et ça s'est transformé en une chose
immense on ajoute des dizaines de
milliers de nouveaux comptes chaque jour
ce qui était sans précédent à l'époque
Hélène s'appliquait beaucoup dans tous
les aspects de l'entreprise
on jouait tous avec son argent après
tout quand c'est votre argent qui est
sur la table c'est dans votre intérêt de
vous impliquer dans tous les détails
j'ai donc enseigné à 10 membres de ma
famille à faire le service à la
clientèle à partir de chez eux et ma
sœur embauché 12 paires et mère au foyer
d'une petite ville du Nebraska pour
qu'il travaille à la maison ils étaient
tellement bons qu'on a fini par
construire un centre de services à la
clientèle à Omaha oneblraska qui emploie
maintenant 1800 personnes ça très bien
marché on est passé de 0 à une centaine
d'employés en 6 semaines à Omaha c'est
sans doute ce qui a été le plus
compliqué mais on était un peu à court
d'options alors
[Rires]
guidé par sa passion pour la perfection
sa détermination et son dévouement
héroïque au travail Mosk réussit dans
des marchés auparavant jugés impossible
à conquérir
ces attentes envers lui-même ont
toujours été plus élevés que celles
qu'il peut avoir à l'égard des autres il
se donnait donc au maximum
Elon Musk est reconnu pour son rythme de
travail ininterrompu et là seulement
deux modes marche et arrêt il travaille
jour et nuit et en exigeant des autres
Ilan passait ses nuits debout à
travailler il envoyait des courriers à
la minuit une heure ou deux heures du
matin complètement absorbé par un des
problèmes qu'on avait à résoudre
apparemment au début de SpaceX le
personnel avait vraiment du mal à suivre
son rythme il est comme ça ce qu'il n'y
arrive pas non qu'à partir
j'ai trouvé que c'était un bon patron il
est maintenant reconnu pour changer très
fréquemment d'équipe de relations
publiques mais à l'époque j'avais
l'impression que ce serait un emploi
comme les autres dans le domaine
il en allait pas tolérer ça
il attendait beaucoup de son monde comme
nous les uns des autres c'est ce qu'il
faut pour réussir
dans la culture des entreprises en
démarrage on s'attend à ce que tout le
monde travaille tout le temps on arrive
à neuf ou 10h du matin et on ne part pas
avant 9 ou 10h du soir ou même plus tard
il aime travailler jusqu'à minuit tous
les soirs c'était comme ça tout
simplement et c'était excitant c'est
rare que quelqu'un se soit plein de ce
genre de choses parce qu'on avait
vraiment l'impression de changer le
monde
malgré le succès de Paypal
l'entrepreneur est maintenant prise avec
des conflits internes à la suite d'un
désaccord avec son conseil
d'administration mosque est évincé de sa
propre société
alors qu'au chef de la direction de
Paypal mais ils avaient certaines
divergences de pignons au sujet de la
technologie et de l'image de marque de
l'entreprise ça amené à un vote de
défiance visant l'éviction Dillon qui se
trouvait malheureusement en Afrique du
Sud à ce moment-là je lui avais parlé au
téléphone plutôt le même jour et il
m'avait demandé si c'était grave je lui
ai répondu que ça n'était pas tant que
ça une fois rentré chez moi et couché
dans mon lit j'ai commencé à rassembler
tous les morceaux qui j'avais vu au
bureau ce qui était en train de se
passer etc vers 22h30 je me suis assise
de droite dans mon lit et je crois bien
avoir lancé quelques gros mots au
plafond je me suis levé je me suis
retourné au bureau bien sûr tout le
monde était là c'était en train de se
faire ils avaient le conseil au bout du
fil pour évacuer j'ai essayé de lui
parler mais il était dans l'avion j'ai
seulement réussi à le joindre au matin
mais c'était trop tard
je suis sûr qu'il n'était pas très
heureux au début mais il a réagi de
façon admirable
Elon Musk quitte donc Paypal mais en
tant qu'actionnaire principal il y
conserve un rôle consultatif
en 2002
IBH achète l'entreprise faisant de lui
un homme incroyablement riche
c'est là qu'il en a commencé à gagner
beaucoup d'argent il a encaissé environ
165 millions de dollars c'était
fantastique ce qui est étonnant c'est
qu'il a presque tout investi dans ses
nouvelles entreprises il n'a rien mis de
côté pour lui-même il n'a pas pensé à
son gain personnel du moins à court
terme il a investi 100 millions de
dollars dans Space ex 70 millions d’un
Tesla et environ 20 millions dans 1000
la plupart des gens diraient 165
millions ça va me durer toute la vie où
se trouve la plage allons-y Paris je le
respecte beaucoup pour ça
en 2001 l'homme d'affaires sud-africain
crée la Fondation Mosk qui offre des
systèmes d'énergie solaire aux régions
du monde frappées par des catastrophes
naturelles il s'engage également à
consacrer au moins la moitié de sa
fortune à la philanthropie bien des gens
pensent que les entrepreneurs sont
motivés par l'argent c'est pour ça qu'il
lance des entreprises en série ils en
veulent toujours plus vraiment après 50
millions qui a besoin d'en gagner plus
ce n'est pas un facteur déterminant ils
ne sont pas du tout motivés par l'argent
il en est conscient sans aucun doute
quand on a 20 milliard dans ces coffres
je suis sûr qu'on finit par leur marquer
mais je ne crois pas que ce soit sa
principale motivation il a une vision
beaucoup plus vaste qui dépasse cette
chose appelée argent mais l'argent
l'aide à réaliser son rêve c'est donc
nécessaire
ce n'est manifestement plus une question
d'argent à l'heure actuelle il a compris
que sur cette terre il est plus
intéressant de consacrer son temps à des
choses qu'on trouve significatives et
qui nous tiennent à cœur et c'est ce
qu'il fait c'est comme une drogue quand
on réussit un projet on veut en lancer
un autre avec une nouvelle vision et
continuer d'apprendre c'est une façon
d'être il s'ennuierait à la plage
il lui faut un grand objectif qui va
changer le monde pour se lever le matin
c'est dans sa nature je ne m'attends pas
à ce que ça change
je crois qu'il y aura une différence
palpable si nous passons bientôt au
transport durable au lieu de remettre ça
plus tard on ne fait pas ça pour devenir
riche je croyais au début qu'on avait
peut-être 10 % de chances de succès
j'étais convaincu que j'allais perdre
beaucoup d'argent ça presque été le cas
d'ailleurs ce n'était donc pas une
évidence j'ai failli tout perdre
après avoir conquis le cyber espace
mosque se tourne vers l'espace
interplanétaire
en 2002 il lance l'une des entreprises
les plus révolutionnaires de notre
époque est bouleverse l'industrie
spatiale
la percée décisive cruciale qui va nous
permettre d'exporter la vie sur d'autres
planètes c'est une fusée orbitale
entièrement et rapidement réutilisable
c'est une chose très difficile parce que
nous vivons sur une planète où cet appel
faisable au cours des 12 derniers mois
je suis quand même arrivé à la
conclusion qu'il est possible de
résoudre ce problème et space va tenter
de le faire on va peut-être échouer le
succès n'est pas garanti mais au moins
on va essayer
au début personne ne croyait qu'il
parviendrait à ses fins c'est un
Sud-Africain apparu comme ça dans les
années 2000 il disait vouloir construire
une fusée capable de mettre des objets
en orbite et se poser au sol pour 10
fois moins cher que les autres la
plupart du monde se moquaient de lui les
gens l'ont ignoré au départ mais il a
joué le geste à la parole en
investissant lui-même une fois il s'est
rendu en Russie pour essayer d'y acheter
des moteurs de fusée mais les ingénieurs
russes sont réduits il est donc rentrés
aux États-Unis et il a construit sa
propre fusée
on avait tous l'idée que l'espace c'est
le domaine de la NASA quand il en masque
et SpaceX ont commencé à expérimenter
avec leur fusée on a compris que c'était
des acteurs sérieux en exploration
spatiale
les trois premiers lancements de Space
exhu ce qui attise le scepticisme de
plusieurs investisseurs
[Musique]
de Space ex Mosk investit dans Tesla
Motors un constructeur de véhicules
électriques dont l'objectif est de
produire une voiture puissante mais non
polluante en quelques années à peine
Tesla s'empare de la tête dans ce marché
spécialisé notre but c'était vraiment de
créer la meilleure voiture au monde afin
de prouver que la meilleure voiture peut
être électrique bien des gens croient
que les véhicules électriques ont des
problèmes et que ceux qui en achètent
sont tous des fétichistes de
l'électrique
il est incroyablement important pour
nous de briser cette perception et de
montrer que les voitures électriques
peuvent effectivement être meilleures
que n'importe quel véhicule à essence
la révolution électrique qui approche
dans le milieu de l'automobile c'était
cela qu'il a lancé
il y a déjà eu plusieurs tentatives
d'introduire des véhicules électriques
elles ont échoué parce que les géants de
l'automobile ne voulaient pas qu'elle
réussisse
ilon ne connaissait rien en voiture
électrique quand il a commencé mais il a
constaté qu'il y avait un problème à
résoudre et il s'y est attaqué comme un
bulldozer
je suis très excité par le fait que nous
avons une voiture sport zéro émission
capable d'affronter une Ferrari et une
Porsche et de les battre
c'est ça qui change la donne un
technologue qui débarque dans l'espace
voiture pour ilon ce n'est pas une
voiture c'est un logiciel avec un peu de
matériel autour tout le monde s'extasie
sur l'expérience de conduite que procure
la Tesla
les Tesla sont rapides et silencieuses
et en plus la technologie se met
elle-même à jour j'ai eu une Tesla
pendant un certain temps j'ai monté le
matin et la mise à jour du logiciel
s'était faite comme pour un téléphone la
voiture avait de nouvelles fonctions
on peut faire sortir un Tesla d'une
place de stationnement avec un téléphone
intelligent c'est tout simplement
incroyable pour quelqu'un qui aime les
voitures et la technologie la France et
le Royaume-Uni entre autres prévoit
interdire la vente de voiture à essence
dans les 10 ou 20 prochaines années
c'est surtout grâce à Tesla
face à la baisse massive du prix du
pétrole il devient plus urgent encore
que les constructeurs automobiles
consacrent de grands efforts à leur
programme de véhicules électriques
ce qui est étonnant c'est que
l'industrie automobile le suive dans
cette voie la batterie ou lithium-ion de
Tesla laisse la concurrence loin
derrière
tous les constructeurs automobiles au
monde s'intéressent aux véhicules
électriques ils ont probablement tous
déjà démonter une Tesla pour voir ce qui
se passe en dessous
Tesla a ouvert tous ces brevets on
essaie de faciliter autant que possible
l'avènement des véhicules électriques on
est heureux que d'autres constructeurs
automobiles utilisent notre réseau de
bornes super charger on fait vraiment
tout ce qu'on peut pour accélérer le
passage au transport automobile durable
on sait maintenant que JM et Len Rover
ont l'intention de produire uniquement
des voitures électriques dans un
prochain avenir il y a tellement de
choses que Tesla a fait en premier et
qui pousse tous les autres constructeurs
automobile de la planète à se dire on
devrait faire pareil non le problème
fondamental c'est que les règles
actuelles incitent les gens à produire
du carbone et c'est de la folie quand on
incite les gens à faire quelque chose
ils le font on doit donc envoyer un
message clair aux équipes de négociation
et aux politiciens cette fois il faut un
changement significatif
des éléments essentiels de l'histoire
triomphale Elon Musk et le fait qu'il
frôle le désastre en 2008 de son propre
aveu c'est la pyrannie de sa vie
la crise économique frappe durement ses
entreprises
trois lancements ratés
auraient pu avorter où il aurait pu
décider d'aller vivre sur une île mais
ne l'a pas fait
ce sont des preneurs de risques ils
adorent vivre sur le fil du rasoir bien
sûr les entrepreneurs n'espèrent pas
nécessairement réussir à tout coup ça
contribue d'ailleurs à leur réussite
tous les entrepreneurs échouent
puisqu'ils prennent des risques mais
quand ils le font ils se ressaisissent
et recommencent ils ont une phénoménale
capacité de rebond contrairement à
d'autres qui se laissent s’absorber par
un échec qui se sente bloqué ou qui ne
peuvent rien faire d'autre pendant un
certain temps
les preneurs de risque affrontent leurs
échecs ils rebondissent et se lance dans
une autre entreprise sans cligner des
yeux comme il se doit
[Musique]
bien que ces entreprises soient sur le
point de s'effondrer MOS évite la ruine
in extremis Tesla est sauvé par
l'intervention des investisseurs et
space ex obtient de la NASA un contrat
de 1,6 milliards de dollars américains
l'équipe de Space ex est incroyable elle
repousse vraiment les limites en matière
d'exploration spatiale je crois que les
humains sont naturellement poussés à
explorer c'est le début selon moi d'un
exode de l'être humain ou de là de
l'orbite terrestre basse j'ai vraiment
l'intention d'être là pour voir ça
en 2010 SpaceX a lancé son vaisseau
dragons vers la Station spatiale
internationale c'était le premier engin
spatial privé à s'y arriver ce qui était
incroyable à l'époque
toute l'adrénaline de mon corps s'est
libérée à cet instant là ça a été un
moment extrêmement intense parce que
tout aurait pu mal tourner heureusement
ça s'est bien passé je me suis senti et
je me sens encore très chanceuse
faire ce qu'il dit il a déjà créé des
fusées réutilisables c'est le
fournisseur de la station spatiale la
prochaine étape sera de mettre au point
des versions de son vaisseau dragon
capable de transporter des humains il
tient donc ses promesses
[Musique]
au cours des années qui suivent Tesla
devient le chef de fil du marché des
voitures électriques au point qu'on
considère l'entreprise d'elenmosk comme
la grande réussite du siècle dans
l'industrie automobile américaine
Tesla ne fait pas publicité ce n'est pas
nécessaire selon moi la marque suscite
tellement d'intérêt
tout semble indiquer qu'on sera en
mesure de respecter le calendrier de
production du modèle 3 pour l'année
prochaine et je suis vraiment emballé
par la tournure des événements
plusieurs interroges sur la valeur de
Tesla c'est une entreprise qui ne fait
pas d'argent mais dont la valeur est
énorme
la réputation de Tesla a autant avoir
avec le produit qu'avec celui qui dirige
l'entreprise si les voitures n'étaient
pas bonnes les gens ne les achèteraient
pas mais elles sont bonnes et à la fine
pointe de la technologie c'est pour ça
qu'elles ont leur fidèle
le grand public apprécie son approche
franche et ouverte de la gestion de ces
entreprises si les gens veulent des
véhicules électriques ça va mais vous
devinez ce qui vient ensuite les
voitures sont conducteurs quand on voit
certaines des choses qui se sont
produites avec ces véhicules et qu'on
sait que les ordinateurs peuvent se
tromper je ne suis pas sûr de vouloir
circuler dans une voiture sans
conducteur
les gens sont complètement déroutés
quand on parle des véhicules autonomes
ils ont peut-être cette image mentale
d'une voiture robot en folie ce n'est
vraiment pas comme ça le logiciel passe
par des niveaux extrêmes de validation
avant qu'un seul client n'y est Axel il
se dit toutes sortes d'absurdité entre
autres qu'on utilise des cobayes humains
en fait jusqu'ici c'était
essentiellement de l'aide avancée à la
conduite on utilise le terme pilote
automatique parce que c'est ce qui
s'emploie pour les avions mais la
présomption en avion c'est que le pilote
doit être attentif rester alerte et prêt
à prendre la relève à tout moment pas
qu'il peut aller dormir ou se promener
hors du cockpit
Elon Musk s'attaque à certains des plus
grands défis de la planète
avec Tesla il entend réduire notre
consommation de combustible fossiles
tout en révolutionnant l'industrie de
l'énergie
pour atteindre son objectif et souhaite
non seulement changer notre façon de
consommer de l'énergie mais aussi de la
produire et l'un est président de sowar
City l'un des plus importants
producteurs de systèmes d'énergie
solaire aux États-Unis
les habitants d'un village isolé ou
d'une île quelque part peuvent prendre
les panneaux solaires les combiner avec
le powerworld Tesla et cessé de se
préoccuper des lignes électriques qui ne
sont pas ce qu'il y a de plus jolies
d'ailleurs cette solution fonctionne
n'importe où le fait que le dispositif
se fixe au mur est crucial ça signifie
qu'on n'a pas besoin d'une salle de
batterie ça signifie qu'une famille
normale peut l'installer sur son garage
ou sur le mur extérieur de sa maison
sans que ça prenne de place on peut
aussi complètement se débrancher du
réseau électrique avec ces panneaux
solaires on charge les batteries et
c'est tout plus besoin de rien et ça
coûte seulement 3500 dollars avec solar
City qui fait maintenant partie de Tesla
ilon essaie de rendre les panneaux
solaires plus attrayant pour le marché
de masse
avant les panneaux solaires étaient de
grands carrés noirs encombrants
désormais ils vont être encastrés dans
le toit
en Australie méridionale la batterie
Lithium Ion de Tesla a permis une
diminution des coûts en électricité de
secours
un système de batterie alimenté par des
éoliennes réduit de 90% les frais
relatifs aux pannes d'électricité
ils prennent le surplus d'électricité
produit et l'emmagazine pour le
retourner sur le réseau de cette manière
il gagne jusqu'à 1 million de dollars
par jour cette impressionnant c'est nez
de Paris qu'il a fait sur Twitter un
homme d'affaires australien discutait
avec lui de la faisabilité d'alimenter
une ville uniquement à l'énergie solaire
il a lancé un pari amosk pour qu'il le
fasse dans un délai précis masque a
accepté le défi
il a fait installer les batteries et les
a mis en fonction avant l'échéance tout
ça pour un pari de milliardaires
nous avons conclu un accord avec le
constructeur automobile Tesla sous
réserve d'examens et d'approbation par
les législateurs qui permettra à Tesla
de construire l'usine de batterie la
plus grande et la plus sophistiquée au
monde ici même au Nevada
pourquoi l'appelle-t-on la giga usine
parce qu'il va non seulement s'agir de
la plus grande usine de batterie lithium
yo au monde mais elle va être aussi plus
grande que toutes les usines lithium du
monde réunis c'est donc difficile à
décrire avec des mots mais c'est toute
une usine
[Applaudissements]
depuis le lancement du vaisseau dragon
de Space ex Elon Musk n'a pas cessé
d'innover le lancement de sa première
fusée parle comme heavy en février 2018
donne le coup d'envoi d'une nouvelle
course à l'espace l'équipe de mosques
vient de démontrer le bon fonctionnement
du fuck and heavy ce qui nous place
maintenant à un tout autre niveau pour
envoyer des objets dans l'espace et sur
Mars
décollant de la même rampe de lancement
qu'appolo 11 qui a transporté les
premiers hommes sur la Lune cette fusée
représente une nouvelle ère dans
l'évolution des vols spatiaux le
lancement du Falcon heavy a été
important pour de nombreuses raisons
scientifiques c'est la fusée la plus
puissante à être lancée depuis Saturne 5
qui a emmené l'être humain sur la Lune
[Musique]
nous entrons dans une nouvelle ère
d'exploration spatiale ce qui est
extrêmement excitant une sorte de
continuation du rêve des missions Apollo
j'étais au Centre Spatial pour le
lancement je n'y avais pas vu autant
d'activités depuis le dernier voyage de
la navette en 2011 l'exploration
spatiale recommence vraiment à capter
l'imagination des gens
c'est une grande réussite pour une
entreprise privée que d'avoir construit
lancé une des plus grandes fusées
porteuses de l'histoire
c'est la troisième plus grosse fusée je
mets lancée il y a eu la fusée Saturne 5
d'Apollo et bien sûr celle de la navette
le Falken heavy est de cet ordre de
grandeur c'est vraiment une très grosse
fusée
le Falken heavy peut transporter 64
tonnes c'est beaucoup c'est autant qu'un
camion c'est l'équivalent d'un avion de
ligne 737 rempli de passagers de bagages
et de carburant qu'on lancerait dans
l'espace au-delà de l'orbite terrestre
basse au-delà de la lune et même au-delà
de Mars
ce lancement va également avoir des
implications politiques à mon avis c'est
le gouvernement américain qui finance
les fusées de la NASA
Hélène de démontrer qu'ils peuvent
lancer le Falken heavy avec succès pour
un coup d'environ 100 millions de
dollars soit 10 fois moins que ce que
coûte les lancements de la NASA
c'est-à-dire près d'un milliard chacun
c'est une économie considérable
pour élargir réellement l'accès à
l'espace on doit atteindre la
réutilisabilité complète et rapide de
l'équipement
de toutes les innovations de mosquées
réutilisable pourrait s'avérer la plus
radicale on croyait que cette mission si
elle est probablement réussir mais elle
y avait quand même une chance sur trois
d'échecs
le Saint Graal de l'exploration spatiale
c'est un système de lancement totalment
réutilisable
de voir les fusées folking l'ancien
vaisseau spatial en orbite puis
redescendre et effectuez un atterrissage
d'une précision extrême sur une
plateforme flottante en mer c'est assez
impressionnant
on s'envole dans un avion on n'aurait
jamais l'idée de jeter l'avion une fois
rendu à destination pourquoi le fait-on
avec les fusées spatiales space ex
essaie de corriger ça en montrant la
voix en ce moment et c'est un succès
ilon amène les gens à se demander
pourquoi la NASA construit encore des
fusées si spéciex on est capable
pourquoi faudrait-il construire des
fusées comparables au lieu d'acheter des
siennes
à l'intérieur de la fusée Falken heavy
Éliane plaque qui porte les noms des
6000 employés de Space ex qui ont
travaillé sur le projet ça montre
qu'ilon musk apprécie vraiment les gens
qui travaillent pour lui
de mettre tous ses efforts dans le
développement de fusées beaucoup plus
grosse capable de placer des charges
utiles dans leur [__] terrestre mais
aussi de lancer des vaisseaux avec des
êtres humains à bord jusque dans
l'espace lointain c'est-à-dire vers Mars
je veux permettre à beaucoup de
personnes et de marchandises de se
rendre sur Mars ça n'a rien à voir avec
mon désir de me rendre moi-même sur
cette planète même si ce serait bien je
trouve ça important que notre espèce
notre civilisation soit en voie de
devenir une véritable civilisation
spatiale et une espèce multiplanétaire
Mosk souhaite lancer une mission vers
Mars d'ici 2020
le building Mask est de faire en sorte
que les humains vivent et travaillent en
permanence sur Mars une colonie
martienne quoi
morse est un endroit très spécial il y a
un ciel une variété de paysages de
grandes quantités d'eau gelées et des
saisons c'est donc très similaire à la
terre
l'atmosphère y a beaucoup plus mince que
sur terre mais elle contient du carbone
ainsi que de l'oxygène on pourrait donc
utiliser ce qu'il y a dans l'atmosphère
de Mars comme ressources
l'environnement y est quasi terrestre
c'est comme une seconde demeure pour
nous mais laisse vraiment
et l'espace est-il possible de notre
vivant d'envoyer une fusée sur Mars avec
un équipage je crois bien que voulons
nous le faire voulons nous payer pour ça
c'est une autre question il y a beaucoup
de questions et d'obstacles mais tant
qu'ilon ne viole pas les lois
fondamentales de la physique c'est
possible
mars est accessible et je suis sûr que
nous serons inventés ce qu'il faut pour
y vivre mais il y a beaucoup de
questions et de difficultés à résoudre
avant que ce soit faisable ces masques
dit qu'il va le faire il va probablement
réussir
s'il continue sur cette lancée je ne
vois pas ce qu'il empêcherait d'envoyer
des vaisseaux sur Mars
mosque est le seul parmi ses pères qui
s'impliquent directement dans la
conception l'ingénierie et les décisions
techniques critiques
croyez-moi il en est aussi doué pour le
génie que pour les finances
dès les premiers
argent là-dedans et qu'il engagerait du
personnel technique ingénieux pour s'en
occuper qu'il n'en serait que le
directeur ou le PDG
il s'implique tellement dans le côté
technique s'en est incroyable mais au
fond c'est parce qu'il est d'abord et
avant tout un ingénieur
il aborde le génie et les affaires à peu
près de la même façon c'est un
casse-tête qu'il faut démonter pour
ensuite en rassembler les pièces d'une
manière ou d'une autre
dans son cœur cet homme est un ingénieur
c'est son premier amour il se promène
dans les installations de Space ex et
interroge les employés sur les vecteurs
de poussée ou sur la conception
aérodynamique ce n'est pas typique du
comportement des PDG
certains entrepreneurs sont plus
compétents que d'autres socialement mais
ce n'est pas un prérequis pour eux car
ils se concentre trop sur leur projet
pour ça les
êtres humains socialement compétents
sont sensibles à ceux qui les entourent
mais ça peut les empêcher d'atteindre
leurs objectifs
or les entrepreneurs doivent être
intransigeants dans la poursuite de
leurs objectifs pas nécessairement
intransigeant dans la façon dont il
traite les autres mais bien pour
s'assurer qu'ils suivent leur propre
échéancier
[Musique]
d'investir dans la vie
en 2013 il esquisse les grandes lignes
d'un plan pour un système de transport
qui pourrait transformer la façon dont
l'humanité voyage d'une ville à l'autre
Elon Musk a eu l'idée du transport sous
vide il a publié un article là-dessus en
déclarant qu'il ne développerait pas
lui-même cette technologie mais qui
l'ouvrait la porte aux entreprises
tierces qui voudraient bien s'en charger
le projet hyperloop est un grand intérêt
dans le monde du transport actuellement
pouvoir se rendre de San Francisco à Los
Angeles dans le temps qu'il faut pour
rouler du centre de San Francisco à sa
banlieue ce serait fantastique c'est un
tube sous vide d'un bout à l'autre dans
lequel on envoie une capsule contenant
des passagers il n'y a pas de friction
ni de résistance parce que les capsules
lévitent sont des aimants techniquement
c'est du solide ça va plus vite dans le
vide parce qu'il n'y a pas de friction
ils espèrent atteindre les 800 à 1100
km/h
l'idée Dylon ce sont des tubes qui
reliraient les grandes villes on
pourrait voyager de Los Angeles à New
York en une demi-heure à peine
on va s'en servir pour les marchandises
des 2019 on croit pouvoir transporter
des passagers en toute sécurité par
hyperloop d'ici 2021
Elon Musk compte parmi ceux qui élèvent
le plus la voix contre l'intelligence
artificielle et son potentiel
apocalyptique il estime que la super
intelligence numérique et la menace la
plus sérieuse pour la survie de l'espèce
humaine
il lance donc en 2016 à l'entreprise
neuralink dédiée au développement d'une
intelligence artificielle sûre et
bénéfique
le danger de l'intelligence artificielle
c'est la disparition de l'esprit humain
tel qu'on le connaît ces machines vont
être fondamentalement plus intelligentes
que nous et vont apprendre par elle-même
comment garder une longueur d'avance
cette question était-ce beaucoup et
l'homme sa principale préoccupation
c'est que des machines trop
intelligentes n'est plus besoin des
humains on deviendrait obsolète
le pire cauchemar sorti d'un film
d'horreur hollywoodiens n'est rien
comparé à ce qui s'en vient
il viendra un moment où ses cerveaux
artificiels auront la capacité de penser
de tirer des conclusions de porter des
jugements etc tout comme l'esprit humain
avec toutes ces facultés n'y a-t-il pas
ne serait-ce qu'une toute petite chance
que l'intelligence artificielle prenne
le contrôle de la planète
[Musique]
si ces machines deviennent conscientes
comment les contrôler qui va contrôler
leur contrôleur c'est une perspective
effrayante
quelle est la probabilité que
l'intelligence artificielle prenne le
contrôle absolu vous le savez c'est 100%
c'est la fin de l'humanité quand nos
logiciels vont s'élever contre nous et
devenir tout-puissant vers qui va-t-on
se tourner on va espérer que les géants
de l'industrie soient capables de leur
faire contrepoids il en est en excellent
position pour se faire le contrepoint de
cette domination logiciel c'est
intéressant qu'il explore l'intelligence
artificielle de façon ouverte avec
neuralink
quand j'entends Elon Musk dire que la
révolution de l'intelligence
artificielle c'est l'humanité qui
invoque le démon je suis tout à fait
d'accord
mais il a fondé une société appelée
neuralink dont le but est de relier
l'intelligence artificielle au cerveau
humain cette contradiction est si
criante que je suis incapable de
m'expliquer ces processus mentaux
est une réponse directe au
préoccupations Dylan face à
l'intelligence artificielle il croit que
dia pourrait surpasser les capacités
mentales des humains c'est donc logique
qu'il essaie de développer une
technologie pour combiner les
ordinateurs à notre nature biologique
je pense que Mosk veut utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle comme un
outil pour augmenter nos capacités et
non pour nous remplacer
son idée c'est que si on n'arrive pas à
garder le dessus il va nous falloir
devenir des surhommes pour y parvenir
les interfaces servent ordinateurs
peuvent aider les gens de deux façons
différentes la première étant restaurant
les capacités des personnes handicapées
l'autre est de nous permettre de
dépasser nos limites on pourrait ainsi
par exemple contrôler un ordinateur par
la pensée sans faire un seul geste
c'est la fonction principale d'une telle
interface il y a beaucoup de situations
différentes dans lesquelles cette
technologie peut servir dans le domaine
militaire pour les processus
décisionnels cruciaux et les scénarios
de guerre ou encore dans le secteur de
la santé
quand on parle d'humains hybrides de
machines humaines ou de cybores on parle
donc tous de la même chose
c'est à dire d'utiliser la technologie
pour accroître nos capacités et c'est
tout
le scepticisme de mosquée
de l'intelligence artificielle mène à un
affrontement public avec Marc Zuckerberg
je suis optimiste quant à l'avenir de
l'intelligence artificielle je pense que
ça va apporter un grand nombre de choses
positives que ce soit pour diagnostiquer
et guérir des maladies ou pour assurer
la sécurité sur les routes ou dans la
collectivité va-t-il y avoir des
problèmes en chemin bien sûr que oui
aucune technologie émerge entièrement
formée il faut quand même que les
pionniers du domaine soient en mesure
d'y travailler pour amener la
technologie à l'état désiré
je trouve ça très sain que des géants de
la technologie se disputent publiquement
pour que tout le monde puisse se faire
une opinion à ce sujet
c'est devenu un sport spectacle
voit ilon comme un pessimiste qui essaie
d’arrêter le développement de l'IA je
comprends les deux points de vue je
penche un peu plus du côté de Zuckerberg
car je pense qu'on est capable de
maîtriser suffisamment bien lia pour
protéger l'humanité je ne parierai pas
contre Ilan si les convaincu que
l'intelligence artificielle va prendre
le dessus et décider que les humains
irrationnels que nous sommes sont
inutiles j'aurais tendance à le croire
il ne s'est pas trompé souvent le débat
actuel pose ceux qui croient que c'est
bon et qu'on doit le faire à ceux qui
croient que c'est mal mais qu'on doit
quand même le faire d'une autre manière
il faut mettre fin à Side immédiatement
avant d'arriver au point où l'humanité
cesse d'exister
il y a une différence entre ce qui est
faisable et ce qui est acceptable ce
n'est pas quelque chose dont il a une
masse qui est Mark Zucker vont décider
ça nous concerne tous vous moi et les
autres et j'espère que ça va se traduire
en législation
frustré de toujours rester coincé dans
des embouteillages mosque a mis sur pied
de boring Company une société
d'excavation de tunnel en 2018 c'est
elle qui a été choisie pour construire
un réseau de transport souterrains à
grande vitesse à Chicago j'aimerais
remercier le maire et son personnel
ainsi que la ville de Chicago d'avoir eu
foi en de boring Company pour creuser
ces tunnels faites-nous confiance on
devrait être capable de toucher le fond
on pourrait presque dire qu'il en a une
touche magique quand il a fondé de
boring Company qui n'a rien d'endu mieux
malgré le double sens du mot boring en
anglais il a décidé de vendre des
casquettes en ligne avant de faire quoi
que ce soit d'autre ça généré des
revenus d'un million de dollars tout ce
qu'il touche se transforme en or c'est
une chose ardues qu'on s'apprête à faire
ici c'est difficile c'est novateur et
j'espère que vous allez nous encourager
si on réussit ça va être très positif
pour la ville si on échoue et bien je
suppose que moi et les autres
investisseurs on va perdre beaucoup
d'argent
sa plus grande réalisation c'est d'avoir
inspiré l'humanité à avoir plus grand à
rêver plus grand
dans un monde où il y a tant de
problèmes ce n'est pas agréable d'avoir
un peu de positif à l'occasion on est
tous là à attendre de voir ce qu'il va
sortir ensuite
[Musique]